[Música]
o la gente
para qué sirve ser dominicano
cuando yo iba a grabar mi cuarto álbum
de estudio tuve la suerte de trabajar
con un gran artista argentino como
productor se llama pablo dacal lo
primero que me dijo fue olvídate de que
vamos a hacer rock y que vamos a hacer
todo eso que tú tiene en la cabeza yo
necesito que tú me ve todo lo que tú
puedas como dominicano
eso es lo que a mí me interesa
eso cambió mi carrera porque me hizo
mirar por primera vez en mi vida en una
dirección hacia la que no había mirado
nunca
hacia adentro
en nuestro país hubo un big-bang
cultural llegaron los españoles en 1492
con esclavos africanos se juntaron con
los taínos y terminaron a los taínos y
nació una nueva raza
que era la suma de los tres allí se
mezclaron culturas y todavía tenemos
influencia directamente relacionada a
ellas
ay
en esa nueva raza no pasa no le pasaron
400 años sin tener una música propia ya
los 376 años tengan su propia música que
era tocada con guitarra española
marímbula y percusión africana y esa voz
que se había creado con el paso del
tiempo
esta esta nueva esta mamá música que
había en el mundo según rafael chaljub
mejía en su libro 'los por los caminos
del merengue
nace cuando baudilio grullón un
empresario un hombre de negocios
exitosos ricachón visita el pueblo de
juan gómez en la vega en su caballo y se
encuentra un grupo de muchachas
machacando semillas de cañafístola para
chupar de la miel
galán romántico desde su caballo dedica
un poema a dolores pérez dolores pérez
mejor conocida como lola lola la de juan
gómez
cuando él le recita el poema lola como
buena dominicana se burla de él por
supuesto y la demás también
y baudilio regresa con su caballo con el
rabo entre las piernas
sin embargo no se rinde como buen
dominicano baudilio llega a su casa y se
fue a saber cómo hacer la remontada
poco tiempo después vuelve en su caballo
se baja esta vez prendió y le canta una
canción
le fue tan bien que él ahora terminó
casándose con baudilio finalmente así
nació el primer merengue completo de la
historia juan gómez
o la que por supuesto se burló de él
termino casada y siendo como
protagonista de este merengue
el merengue
tenía una particularidad y era que
comenzaba ya a popularizarse sin embargo
se hacía muy incómodo escucharlo en las
fiestas y en los campos porque no había
amplificación entonces la guitarra
sonaba muy bajita y se complicado
entonces trataban de resolver la
situación buscando el 3 por ejemplo y
otros instrumentos que pudieran
sustituirla pero no daban pie con bola
hasta que un día llegó un barco de
alemania y un campesino que había bajado
del cibao al puerto
está trabajando sacando caras y otra vez
buen dominicano se pone de fresco a ver
qué era lo que había por todos los
rincones ya habiendo terminado su
trabajo y ahí descubre un objeto extraño
rarísimo como con una tecla y una cosa
el acordeón
fíjense que el acordeón aquí se toca de
una manera distinta al resto del mundo
en ninguna parte del mundo se tocan
igual que aquí porque porque este hombre
agarra eso de esa tecla comienza a darle
para allá y como venían en un solo tono
no importaba lo que hicieran con él
caían en la escala correcta y entonces
el sube con ese elemento en la mano al
cibao y la gente empieza a conocer los
bajan los otros buscar más y piden más y
entonces entra el acordeón al merengue
lo impacta como impactaría el meteorito
que cayó en júpiter a nosotros porque lo
cambió definitivamente aporta por un
lado la sonoridad pero les resta
capacidad creativa porque perdemos los
acordes menores y le damos un solo una
sola sensación que la sensación de
alegría porque todos venían en tonos
mayores y sobre todo a partir de los
griegos en la época del renacimiento en
el que se le asigna ya una sensación de
alegría a los tonos mayores incluso con
especificaciones muy claras y es por esa
razón que el merengue no importa lo que
cante es alegre y por eso a menudo
nosotros cantamos y contamos nuestras
desgracias con alegría y enfrentamos las
cosas con alegría por ejemplo fíjense
como nosotros encaramos la muerte en
algún momento
la muerte de martín
dice emilio martín y yo no lo sabía
emilio martín que yo no lo sabía
[Música]
pero en esto siempre memoria
mis manos y en mi mano está el flor por
arriba
increíble pero hay caso más dramático
como el aixiña juanita después vio sin
agua ni acá se me muere y niño y no
tengo medicina hagan qué cosa tan
dramática y tan fuerte que revela la
pobreza la miseria la situación de un
niño muriéndose pero por supuesto con
alegría como somos nosotros
eso me llevó a pensar que lo que pasa es
que eso no nos ha ido llevando por un
camino en el que siempre que nosotros
encontramos un dominicano en el salón o
en una ciudad o en un país ya todo va
está bien todo va a salir bien vamos a
tener siempre una cucharadita de azúcar
un chin de arroz una cama un sofá en el
que vamos a dormir porque somos
solidarios entre nosotros somos como el
tan igual de nosotros mismos
y siempre que nos juntamos superamos
cualquier obstáculo
podemos estar solo en nueva york y poder
hacer en nueva york con un dominicano y
ya yo sé que no voy a pasar frío
y así ha ido pasando históricamente
por ejemplo cuando un grupo de
dominicanos se juntan y acaban con una
dictadura
eso landon igual ahora cuando la
invasión norteamericana del 16
[Música]
en el año 16 que los americanos
pisoteando con sus botas
en el suelo dominicano erick escarbar
defendiendo la bandera y yo no pueden
mandar no a yanquis en nuestra tierra
ellos se sacándole pecho a la gringa
yo quiera pero
qué pasa cuando nos juntamos
miren lo que pasó a ustedes les sale por
familia y se junta con kinect
viento a quien no le gusta el agua de
coco
y cuando la juventud se une en una plaza
y con música defiende a los haitís de
una cementera
y cuando se une muchísima gente reclama
el 4% por la educación se logró
yo me pregunto para qué sirve ser
dominicano bueno para bailar la muerte
para enfrentar cualquier cosa con
alegría y con cierta temeridad que
resulta inocente y graciosa por momento
también para sufrir el amarga como nadie
para demostrar de lo que somos capaces
cuando están oficiando también
para el ritmo para ser trabajador para
celebrar por lo que sea dice pedro
valdés que el dominicano celebra lo
tanto por lo que sea que celebramos el
día en el día de independencia pero el
día antes celebramos que viene la
independencia
celebramos la bienvenida pero la
despedida también y la semana antes
celebramos que la última semana que le
queda entonces
es una cosa increíble y por eso yo estoy
defendiendo mucho el hecho de que se
está redefiniendo involuntariamente a
nuestra identidad
se está viendo al dominicano como un ser
violento materialista abusivo y eso no
es lo que son
nosotros lo que siempre hemos sido a
gente alegre
trabajadora
solidaria qué pasó cuando el ciclón
georges salió todo el mundo a la calle a
quitarlo de cobre a quitar del vecino
también cuando el terremoto en haití
cada vez que nos unimos enfrentamos
cosas grandes no somos corruptos
y queremos bueno yo quiero decirle
a esa gente que se va
cada vez más la juventud se quiere ir
del país el que sí que se vayan a buscar
una mejor vida pero que no se olviden de
esa esencia que es la que elevada la
fuerza para luchar y tirar p'alante a lo
que se quedaron lo que volvieron que
levanten la cabeza
y se sientan orgullosos de ser lo que
son porque ser dominicanos
hay mucho más que tener una bandera que
tener fronteras que canta el himno
se dominicano y lleva en el alma una
pieza que forma un rompecabezas cuando
estamos
y nos hace poderosos y capaces de
cambiar la cosa
eso fue lo que descubrí cuando miré
hacia adentro
es sacar lo que realmente somos para
encarar los obstáculos de la vida y por
eso yo quisiera invitarlos a todos a
sentirse orgullosos y a compartir la
alegría de ser dominicanos
gracias